well hey everybody what's going on it's
Monday night what happened man you got
the uh I didn't do
it why you blame me all the time you got
the the microphone in in the shop why
you blame me all the time there you go
the microphone's always in the shop is
it in the shop I'm pretty sure it's
always shot don't touch the but don't
touch the button didn't touch it let's
see light still okay it's still yeah but
hey everybody what's going on so uh
Danny says hell yeah good luck on this
awesome episode review Jenny and Tom
double thumbs up for this episode was
this not your idea to do this because we
said that we just bought Tom just bought
the um the DVD that has a haunting in
Connecticut and a haunting in Georgia on
one disc yeah they The Haunting um uh
pilots pilots yeah yeah they they come
on DVD I got think I got two of them for
like eight bucks delivered yeah might
have been less I think it was $5 $5 wor
shipping on top of it something it'll be
about eight and uh we saw
Connecticut and uh boy I didn't realize
how crude the the pilots were compared
to the the later episode lat cuz we
hadn't seen it I mean we have talked
about this episode
before like the pilot episode of
Haunting in Connecticut uh which came
out in
2002 which was a long time ago now um
you know because we've talked about this
SAR case and everything like that but
we've never done and like I said I think
this was Danny's idea too we've never
done a thing where we compared the
actual real case or the episode of
Haunting the pilot episode of Haunting
to the actual Hollywood quote unquote
movie that they made about the case in
2009 now we're going to do the same same
thing to uh The Haunting in Georgia too
we were actually going to do all of them
on One show and then Tom's like man
that's going to be like too much and I
was just like yeah you're right yeah so
we're just going to do like one at a
time that we also uh did some research
and watched the Sally Jesse Raphael that
show that they appeared on and uh I
think that's about the only thing that
you can really they had a couple of
little made for TV things but it was
just there's not much content on them um
the Sally Jesse Raphael show that the
sneakers appear on is pretty good it it
it's like I remembered it it is kind of
creepy
um do I believe that this is something
that
happened if it happened I think they
exaggerated some of it or or over over
time it maybe you've got distorted it's
a weird
case um it's it's like a mixture of
Haunting Poulter ghost and possession
all happening in the same case it's it's
like a mishmash but a bunch of
stuff but on the Sally jasse show there
were some neighbors there some of the
neighbors said that they were
bullshitting but they didn't really have
proof of that and then there were some
other neighbors that thought that that
did kind of back up some of the things
the sticer said uh mostly the little
details about how the sign was covered
up that it was a funeral home when they
first got there uh one woman thought
that something strange was happening in
there but they weren't sure
now and and the rain Warren are are
involved in this case which always
raises some red flags yeah whenever
they're involved in then I start to
question it uh Ed Ed bullies his way
through the salad Jesse show um but he
didn't want anybody questioning the case
he he he wanted everybody to believe it
he wants everybody to buy the book God
damn it
yeah just because they were involved in
the case doesn't mean the case was fake
though because they were involved a
little bit into the nfield into the
nfield case but they got kicked off the
nfield case yeah they turned up like one
day they turn one dare Uninvited when
somebody else was already investigating
and they didn't want anything to do with
them this is up in England and that gave
them the right yeah we were involved in
that case yeah involved that case for
one day they threw you out yeah like I
said I didn't even know if they came
inside the house I think they just
showed up on the doorstep and said who
they were in there just like briefly no
I think Witnesses said that they weren't
there long enough to even see anything
right that's what I'm saying yeah so so
is that volume up cuz I keep hearing
like Little Voices over there it's kind
of like distract me I'm like is that us
talking it's like couple seconds behind
that's kind of freaking me out what I
had forgotten oh my God the Sally Jesse
Raphael Show when did that come out
because I kind of feel like the the
sneer case yeah it was like late 80s
right because I think they well they
moved into the house in 86 or ' 87 right
yeah so and then however much longer it
was that after that they were on Sally
Jesse rafhael show I'm like oh my God it
was one it was impossible to look good
in the 80s what the [__] [__] up God
yeah everyone just looked completely
ridiculous yeah um and it's just like
helmet hair and I was that yeah it's
like everything was like shellacked
crazy and I kind of remember when when
people had hair like that and not just
that that it's just like the clothes
just were also really super unflattering
yeah terrible I remember it I do too it
was all [__] you bought at the mall that
was the only clothes you knew about
couldn't order any clothes yeah and you
know no choice almost like Soviet times
I love the I had forgotten about this
lady but okay there are two things that
I absolutely loved about this about the
sneers on Sally Jesse Raphael yeah one I
love that Sally brought in a mockup of
their bed yeah and made them sit in it
and like demonstrate but they didn't
even demonstrate anything they just kind
of sat in it and told like part of the
story and I'm just like that was really
weird that is very weird I'm just like
why so yeah why don't you go sit in this
bed that looks like your actual bed and
tell us about what happened and I was
just kind of like whose idea was that
super bizarre weird [__] they would do
in the 80s yeah and I was just like why
I don't know oh and also I love some
music back there yeah like they they
turned the lights down play music so
it's like so you could all look you're
in the bedroom with the neers I'm like I
I don't want to be in their bedroom okay
this is like a little bit weird was how
they were going to Rea reenact it
nowadays they would have done video
reenactment of it I know but I guess
just so weird was a little too expensive
for forgotten about that and just like
they pan over it's just like there's a
bed with like a gold headboard and like
and I'm just like oh my God that is the
weirdest [__] thing I've ever seen
special effects man I don't know oh and
I also loved that they had that [__]
Karen out in the audience yeah who was a
neighbor of theirs who she was like
trying to debunk all the [__] and she
had this yellow uh like college ruled
notebook yeah and I guess she had
written down because she doesn't have
anything [__] better to do with her
life I guess she had written down like
every single thing that happened in the
neighborhood that would explain the
so-called paranormal uh TR by and like
at 3:20 a.m. I'm like woman get a hobby
like not this one get get a good hobby I
saw a program where they where they
where it was a program it had a
psychologist on there and they mentioned
the Ken the Caren effect the Karen
phenomenon K Ken phenomenon and he said
yeah says when you find a Karen if you
actually look at pictures of her when
she was young and you hear from her
friends what she was like what you're
seeing is you're seeing pretty girl
privilege with [__] ages ages out
it's big time that was a pretty girl who
had a lot of privilege at one time well
some of them are still pretty like when
they get older but yeah yeah that's
definitely that yeah but you know if you
see one in her 50s and she's over the
hill and she's being a carrot as [__]
she was hot when she was a teenager she
got away with some [__] yeah she she got
used to being treated a certain way and
it went away and little I you know what
it's like I don't even know what my
[__] neighbors names are I don't get
I don't get involved in the [__]
business you know what I mean like yeah
if they're loud a [__] about it I'm not
going to go over there and like say
anything cuz they probably shoot me in
the face but you know what I mean it's
just kind of like I don't understand
being that invested in someone else's
life that you'd be like over there I'm
going to keep track of every
[__] thing look they came out
of the house and they looked happy it
doesn't look like they were haunted like
get when the case started um the the
whole neighborhood knew about it
evidently I guess so so it attracted
their attention so they tried to find
anything they could to kind of well it
wasn't I don't think everybody
disbelieved him but the ones that did
disbelieve him were there and and they
had them on the
panel but really the things that they
said didn't didn't dispel it for me
didn't dis buunk it for me everybody was
just yelling at each other yell it's
like I couldn't really tell like half
half of the show I couldn't tell they
were just saying that they were frauds
and that they were just that they were
behind on the rent and they just made
the story up to make money but they you
have to demonstrate some kind of proof
and and then they went well yeah your
young son he was also on drugs he was on
LSD and she goes yeah he was he had a
lot of problems but that was after all
this stuff happened so you know I mean
because that's when he got older I don't
know because I do kind of feel like and
the thing about it is that when they did
the episode of Haunting about the
sneaker family which you know I want to
talk about that because I had forgotten
but like we talked about it like a few
years ago but I had forgotten how one
they changed their names they don't call
them the sneers they change the name and
they're all like they they talk to
Carmen and they talk to the um the niece
right yeah I think her real name is
Tammy yeah but they changed everybody's
names and they put them all in Shadow
yeah so I cuz cuz I was thinking because
they were also on Paranormal Witness
yeah and they showed their faces on that
one and used their real names on that
one so I was maybe like confusing it
with that like they did Paranormal
Witness like later on yeah it is a weird
case um they show they showed Miss s her
name was Carmen Carman yeah yeah they
showed Carmen from around the time of
the incident
uh she changed by the time she was on
Sally Jesse Raphael but there was some
other videos that we saw that showed her
video of her from that time and she was
she was cute she was real thin the hair
on the Sally Jesse show did not give do
her any favors yeah they all started to
look like televangelist and [__] there
was like triangular yeah so and then the
uh the little the niece and everything
you know she was they you know young and
thin she was still young and thin when
she was on Sal Jazz so having been
through a poltergeist case
myself I think I think that might have
been a sexually kind of charged
environment where maybe because this
something like this might happen because
this manifestation this Poltergeist
outbreak I think it's Poltergeist
actually um it's just just a weird one
if it did happen um evidently the
phenomenon was was very sexual it was
raping them much like the entity like
the entity yeah and uh a lot of butt
hking going on on and but horking the
dude too he was getting pegged that
ghost was but horking everybody yeah
yeah the [__] Cara sneer and her
niece were running down the street
together getting pegged why they were in
public she said outside the house some
weird [__] man kinky how do you make up
I wouldn't have even thought to make up
something like that I might have but you
know what I mean I think of Weir [__]
like that then they were asking Mr
snaker what was his Mr sneaker's name um
Allan I think his name was Allan's
probably in his third at the time the
Sally's show and he said that he had
been penetrated and stuff and then later
on they were asking him you know what
that was like and he says well says it's
not like a a personto person thing it
doesn't it's not
real sex but you can feel it so I you
know it's stinging and [__] yeah he said
it was like a stinging sensation so I
don't know what he's talking about in
the booty he didn't say that Lois felt
that she got touched by hand once at the
and it snake and wrapped around her like
a snake and went into the floor so maybe
that's kind of what he's talking about
it's kind of like a ghost feeling you
know just something odd he said he said
it he said it didn't feel like a a
person touching you or like an actual
yeah or actual penetration type of deal
but it just gave you that impression but
it was weird it was kind of confusing
the the kind of confusing the
descriptions they were both using for
for but it was yeah it was very it was
very
sexual there was yeah this if this was a
good which I don't think it was but if
it was it was a it was a big [__]
pervert Yeah it was all perved out big
time it was doing all kind of [__] like
that yeah Danny says pulling people's
bras down yeah trying to get in bed with
them feeling up their boobs and whatnot
Danny says Carmen sneer aged nicely in
my opinion she looks good just saying um
yeah Tom like made that uh comment too
that when she was younger she looked
kind of cute I said yeah she was kind of
cute she kind of looked like if Karen
Black and Steven Tyler had a baby yeah
yeah yeah yeah she kind of looked like
The Offspring of those two if that ever
happened because I like the bottom half
of her face reminded me of Stephen Tyler
like not in a bad way like when he was
young you know do I think all this case
is a
fraud I'm not going to go that far I
think something might have happened
there but I'm not sure we'll ever really
I don't know it seems kind of crazy I
did put it in my book uh but I put it in
there as a polter guys case because it's
all over the place and when they were on
Sally Jesse Raphael um they had Joe
nickel on there who I was really he
writes for skeptical inquire
and I've read a couple of his books um I
read one about secrets of the sidh shows
remember we did that Sideshow like
circus Sideshow uh show a long time ago
like I use that book as a primary source
so he was on there and he did make the
point that it's like you know usually if
you have like a haunting or a polter
guys thing it's like it usually follows
kind of like a pattern there's like
tropes to it or whatever and he's like
and this one just seemed like it was all
over the place and I think they did
bring up I don't remember if somebody
brought it up on the Sally Jesse Raphael
Show or if somebody brought it up on
another documentary that we watched
about it but they said that Carmen and
her niece were big fans of that movie
The Entity yeah which we've done a show
about that a very long time ago which
was like the Doris bther case and that
one also had apparently Supernatural uh
sexual assault so they were kind of
implying that maybe that's where they
got the idea from but when pist activity
happens it's real open to suggestion
whatever you woring about that's kind of
what it does so maybe they liked that
movie and they were afraid they were
going to get sexually assaulted so
that's what it did right that's another
way to look at it that's why I'm saying
I'm not real not real quick to just
throw it out um I'm not either I wasn't
there but it's just was there it's a
weird ass case though
yeah so um so like I said one thing that
I had forgotten about about the haunting
A Haunting in Connecticut the pilot
episode was from 2002
um I had forgotten one that they changed
everyone's names that everyone was just
in uh Shadow like I think they had
Carmen on there they had Tammy on there
um was that it was that like all of the
real people that were on there it was
just Carmen and
Tammy no it was it was um Tammy's
boyfriend no Tammy's remember there this
young guy there remember oh that was one
of the younger brothers one of the
younger brothers that's cuz they had
four kids yeah one of the younger
brothers yeah that's right yeah one of
the younger kids right but he was in
Shadow also yeah cuz I knew there was
one more person and I they didn't have
Allen on there I don't know if did they
get divorced later on I don't remember I
don't know but so I think we've done a
show about this before like I said they
changed everyone's names but they kind
of kept most of the details the same I
don't know if they ever mentioned where
the sers lived prior to the moving to
this house in Connecticut I'm assuming
it was was another state because they
were talking about how far a drive it
was and they were saying we have to
drive into Connecticut or he had got his
job transferred into Connecticut so I'm
assuming they lived in a neighboring
state is what I'm imagining but I don't
know if anybody I don't think they
mentioned where that was so yeah this
happened in the 80s now they had a kid
who I think at the time he was what 14
somewhere around there yeah and he had
Hodgkins
lymphoma and he had to go get these
treatments at this hospital at
University of Connecticut because it was
like Specialists and stuff like that and
wherever it was that they lived it was
like a 4-Hour drive like each way and
they had to go like every day so Carmen
is driving the kid's name real name is
Philip but they called him something
else on the show and I don't remember
what it was but so they're driving him
back and forth um you know he can't
really it's wearing him out and it's
just really far and so basically they're
just like well maybe we should until his
treatments are finished maybe we should
I mean you know understandably maybe we
should rent a house closer to the
hospital so we don't have to like
[__] drive back and forth all the
time CU it's [__] 8 hours I mean
that's like a whole work day they were
just
driving so they do that now Carmen on
the show she says I don't even remember
what they what her name was like what
her pseudonym was that they called her
on the show I don't know Kathy Karen
something like that something like that
but I'm just going to call her Carmen
cuz I know what I know what her real
name was so she's like well I we had
four
kids and a lot of places won't rent to
you if you have that many kids which is
true that was true when I was growing up
as well cuz my parents ran into that
also cuz they also had four kids and
some landlords were like oh no you know
what I mean you're going to tear this
[__]
up so she was just having a real hard
time finding something that would be
large enough for them but you know
within their budget which I'm imagining
was not excessive um she worked although
I don't think they said what she did
because here's the thing like I'm she
said she was working at the time but
it's like how did she have the time to
drive for eight hours like the sun back
and forth I don't know maybe she taken a
leave of absence or something and I
think her husband Allan was it like in
construction like he was a contractor or
something like that so maybe he made a
lot of money yeah so I'm assuming well
they'd had to he'd had to have make a
pretty good amount of money just to pay
for the right the doctor's bills yeah I
mean it's like and that was the thing
and that kind of like factored in later
on because I'm just like holy crap like
cancer treatment that's like millions
and millions of dollars I mean you would
just never pay that off back then yeah
um yeah so and then plus having to pay
like all the expenses to the house and
they have like three other kids too that
are younger yeah so you know feeding
them and all that other kind of crap
because probably I don't know where they
get all this money from so she's looking
around she can't find anything and then
she stumbles across this house she says
that she was just driving around the
neighborhoods close to the hospital and
saw saw the forent sign in the yard and
she said the house looked big um so she
didn't think she'd be able to afford it
but apparently the GU gave her a figure
and it was reasonable now what they
didn't mention in the a haunting episode
or in the Hollywood movie that they made
a it later which we'll talk about was
that I'm pretty sure the whole house
wasn't theirs I think the house had been
I mean at least from what they were
saying um on the Sally Jesse Raphael
Show and what I read like from outside
sources I think the house had been
portioned out into like Apartments cuz
it's a big house it's still there it's
in um what the hell is the name of that
town Southington or something like that
and it's on Meridian Street I think it's
still there and it used to be a funeral
home which is one of the big things but
I'm pretty sure that while they were
living there like there were other t
you know what I'm saying like living in
other apartment cuz I think it had been
broken up into Apartments yeah that was
kind of what the implication and like I
said on a haunting they didn't mention
that they made it look like oh my God
it's this big house yeah there was one
uh program that we saw they had they
they briefly uh interviewed one of the
tenants that were that was living in
there and she was pissed off the whole
thing this all this ghost business yeah
cuz she's like I lived here for however
long she said she didn't see anything I
didn't see anything she said they br
just make lived upstairs
yeah but um sneer said that she was full
of [__] that she did see it I don't know
I don't know either said she was just
trying to cover it
up Danny says in the TV version when she
was mopping the floor and the water
turned to blood was from Amityville 2
that's right they did do that and that
when did amville 2 come out we just
reviewed that not too long ago didn't we
yeah I don't know what date that was up
um well it came out before 1986 or 1987
that's for sure so so again maybe they
were just getting ideas from movies you
know um he also I said polter guys just
opened a suggestion sure yeah yeah that
doesn't mean it didn't happen that just
means oh we saw the movie we had that
idea that it was going to yeah 1982 he
says that's when that came out or like I
said the the other possibility is that
they saw the [__] in the movies and
they're like oh that seems scary let's
put that in our story and they weren't
Savvy enough to know that other people
had seen that movie I don't know right
yeah maybe it's like um yeah we saw that
movie too
uh yeah he says a necrophiliac funeral
home yeah I kind of feel like the whole
thing about the funeral home nobody said
anything about necrofilia until Ed
Warren and I was like maybe that's your
thing Ed among other things Ed's trying
to figure out why is it a funeral home
why is this [__] so sexual well they
were having sex with but he but he's he
he's he's quick to say it's wasn't the
owner of the funeral home though just
some lowlevel person that work there you
know
didn't name he didn't want to get sued
sure you know yeah because if you said
hey this [__] that used to work
there it's like he used to [__] the dead
bodies it's like I'd be like yeah I'd be
suing your ass for [__] liel Ed
Warren I don't care how much you like
threaten to punch me he was real careful
I'll knock your ass out well he's dead
now so it doesn't matter but every time
every time I heard him mention that
heard mention it twice on two different
shows he says it wasn't the people that
owned the uh the funeral home they
weren't doing it but something was going
on there at one time or another just
that kind of [__] right
like I said I I think that's maybe Ed
Warren's fantasy
yeah Ed Ed liked uh he liked
sensationalism man he tried to sell he
was into selling these cases because
they wanted to write books about them
and have their little Museum and stuff
and know this it was this was their
livelihood was their livelihood yeah
because they didn't as far as I'm aware
because we've done a couple shows about
the Warren as far as I'm aware they
didn't directly charge money to the
families who they helped I don't know if
that's the the case or not but some of
the families that they helped said yeah
they didn't charge me any money they
just wanted wrs to the story and I yeah
and I think that's how they made their
money out of it is that they use the
stories and turn them into books and
lecture tours and things like that that
they would sell so that's how they ended
up making money out of the people's
stories but they didn't charge the
families directly as far as I'm aware
well most of the families didn't have
money anyway that's what I'm saying and
they wanted to be included on the case
so they got their street crit because
maybe the family was hoping too that
it's like hey we're going to cash in
like Amityville Horror you know what I
mean cuz look at that that that book
sold a bajillion copies and that movie
was like a huge hit back in the 70s so
I'm sure somebody got like a good a
chunk of change out of that but yeah the
guy that wrote the
book um about this case was a horror
fiction writer named Ray garton and the
book was called in a dark place in a
dark place in the dark place I can't
remember but it was one of those now Ray
garton has gone on record as saying he
kind of um
he's kind of like I he sort of what's
the word that I'm looking for um where
you like abandon something uh you
abandon well you know what I mean no I
don't know he disowned it he disowned it
that's the word I was looking for
disowned it I'm losing my mind I swear
to God um so he disowned the book well
I'm sure that'll help me as my mind go
her feet are like this big right now I
thought you didn't like feet I like them
now oh okay I like them now you like I
like them now yeah I don't even have any
shoes on them okay so that's that's
really looking cute I even have a little
painted toenail
hor he's on the hormones to suddenly he
likes yeah I like that's really funny
because he used to tell me before he's
like oh my God feet are so gross but I
guess not anymore but um but yeah so he
said he's disowned the book and he
claims that when he interviewed the
sneers for you know to help him write
the book cuz it's supp supposed to be
quote unquote non-fiction he says none
of them could keep their story straight
and he was getting really frustrated and
he asked Ed Warren about it and Ed
Warren just said just make it up and
make it
scary um allegedly so so I don't know I
haven't read the book I don't know like
what it's all about now okay so in The
Haunting episode the first creepy thing
that happens is the mop water right
isn't that the first creepy thing that
happens yeah like I don't know if like
minor [__] well okay because they move
in Now Carmen claims in the defense of
this [__] though having been involved in
a real case when he says they couldn't
keep the story straight I'd like to hear
exactly what had happened because I
remember a lot of [__] that happened and
then in in Mammoth Mountain and I I
forgot a lot of it too and I definitely
didn't remember the order that
everything happened yeah and that's
understandable but but red remembered
more than I did and it was sometimes in
contrary to what I remembered but he was
an adult I was only like 15 at the time
yeah that's enough yeah you're 13 you're
yeah 13 probably yeah so he could
remember it better than I he remembered
a lot of stuff that I'd forgot right
soon as he said it was oh yeah I forgot
about it well like I said he was an
adult and you were a kid I don't
remember [__] from when I was 13 years
old if somebody was trying to write a
book about was Jen wrote a book about
ours it it was kind of hard to keep
certain things straight mostly the order
but honestly y'all's stories were
remarkably consistent I will say that
yeah like little detail differed here
and there like some of you remembered oh
this happened before that happened
you're like no no no that happened
before that happened and like little
details were different but overall and I
interviewed you and I interviewed Lois
and red like separately right um and
y'all all told pretty much the same the
general same story somebody else might
have might have said no they couldn't
keep the story straight depends on how
stringent you know or how unforgiving
somebody is I'm willing to give forg
because like I said I you know I don't
remember when certain [__] happened or
did this happen before that
but if everybody's story isad consistent
then yeah that's that's I would go with
that so I don't know I'm just saying
that the writer said that um and said
that Ed Warren specifically told him
just make stuff up if you can't figure
it out um just make sure it's scary CU
they were just trying to sell books I
guess so that's what they were saying so
I think the first thing that happened so
they move into this place Carmen said
she claimed that she didn't know that it
was a funeral home when they moved in
because because she said I went in there
to look around and it was still being
renovated and the the like the basement
where all the funeral home [__] was was
like blocked off so she couldn't really
go down there so she was just kind of
like looking around upstairs or whatever
and then she was just like yeah this is
like perfect it's only a few minutes
away from the hospital like it's big
enough for all of us cuz I think it was
a five bedroom house I want to say five
bedrooms and two bathrooms and it had
like that big ass basement that you
could use for um for uh bedrooms as well
which the boys did but so she just kind
of went ahead and rented it and then she
says that later she found out it was a
funeral home so this was like a point of
contention because the owner either the
owner or the
landlord um claimed later that it's like
oh we absolutely told her it was a
funeral home and like everybody in town
knew it was a funeral home and like when
they were on Sally Jesse Raphael some
people came on and said oh there was a
big sign out front that said I think it
was Hal was it halahan halahan Funeral
Home was the name of it and they said it
was a big sign out front that still said
that but then like some of their other
neighbors said no this there was a sign
out front but it had plywood over it
like and it had had plywood over it for
years and years so you wouldn't
necessarily know it was a funeral home
another thing too I think in The
Haunting
episode um and we might have brought
this up when we talked about it before I
think they exaggerated how much Funeral
Home [__] was like down there in the
basement cuz I think they said and I I
don't even know if they put this in the
episode and there was um a body hoist in
there that went from the basement up
until up to I believe the master bedroom
cuz that's where they would bring the
bodies up from the you know embalming
room or whatever like up into where the
funeral was held so that was there I did
see footage of the house like the Warren
were in there so the body hoist was in
there but in the haunting episode from
2002 they show them going into this room
and there's basically like a whole
[__] Morgan there man it's just kind
of like all the tools are just laying
there there's like a big [__] gurnie
there's like this that there's like the
tanks that would had form Malahide and
[__] like that in there I don't think it
was quite that egregious you know I
think they did leave some [__] behind
and like I said there was a body hoist
in there I'm sure that's established but
I don't think you know there was like a
table with like a sink there was a
gurnie in there and I think there was a
couple other things like maybe that bone
thing that's like attached to the wall I
think that was there but I think that
was about it and then like later the
landlord came in and removed some of the
[__] they said well they left the body
freezer in there cuz it's like hey it's
a freezer you guys can use it put all
your food in there where all the dead
bodies were I mean you know whatever
they cleaned it it's fine yeah bleach
kill all that sure it's I don't think
I'd be bothered I mean to be honest they
kind of made a big deal about it which I
can see how you would um I don't know
I'm sitting there thinking it's like man
if the rent was that cheap I don't know
how cheap the rent was but they were
saying it's like yeah was real cheap for
like a big a house out size but I I
honestly don't think it would bother me
I don't think it would bother me that
the house was they didn't have it them
all by themselves though that's what I'm
saying and that well that was something
that they didn't really bring up either
in the haunting episode or in the movie
there were other people living in the
house there were it was part portioned
off into apartment yeah it's creepier to
think that they were in there alone and
I think that's probably why they did do
that I think that's why they did that
and
evidently the other person living there
said she didn't see anything
yeah she lived like in an apartment
upstairs cuz if you look at it like I
said it's um the address I think is 208
Meridian Avenue might still be there um
it's a big house like it looks like a
pretty big house I don't know how many
people were living there other than them
yeah you know and a lot of the a lot of
the details of this case have been kind
of erased in both the television show
and the movie and it wasn't in the Sally
Jessie Show I
remember I remember in other talk
shows that they had pictures drawings of
the apparitions that they were seeing
one of them was like a crazy dude in in
Tails like a like a like a butler right
and he was uh evil and then they had
some other guys they talk about the dude
with the black eyes the evil dude yeah
they talk about him in the movie and in
in the uh in The Haunting episode but
the thing is is that he was only one of
them they had about eight of them that
they kept
seeing yeah they got rid of all that
from from you know I guess they were
just trying to simplify the story make
it creepier because how they kind of
approached The Haunting episode was that
they were trying to say I think they I
don't know if they said this out right
but I think they were trying to imply
that this man in the suit that philli
kept seeing was a demon because it was
essentially like controlling his
behavior yeah um they were kind of
ambiguous about it like sometimes
referring to it as a spirit or like an
evil spirit or something but I think
they wanted you to think that it was
like demonic well he was talking bad
about the rest of the family and trying
to talk him into going going up there
and killing him right that's that's
basically all he said and I think the
implication too was tell him to write
poems yeah turned into a goth basically
yeah he's writing poems listening to
heavy metal music yeah like you do but
they were like who and his mom was going
like that that you know why'd you write
that because that the man told me to do
that he that was his poem that's how
yeah I think one of the first things
that happened so so you have Carmen um
saying that she was mopping the kitchen
floor and the mop water turned to blood
interestingly in the fictional movie
adaptation they have that scene happen
but the mom doesn't see it only the son
does yeah which is kind to say that she
didn't believe the kids for a long time
and she thought they were making [__] up
yeah like a year wasn't it yeah it was a
while a year yeah it was a while like
even for a while she thought that the
son Phillip that like the medication
that he was on for the cancer was making
him hallucinate or was giving him like
mental problems cuz she took him to a
psychologist and like all this other
kind of [__] because she thought that he
was having problems like she didn't
believe any of that [__] was real cuz
all the kids seem to see the [__] first
right they they implied in The Haunting
episode that the little girl I don't
know if they said what her name was in
the but her real name was Jennifer
um that she saw a lady in her room like
a ghost lady and also Phillip and his
brother his younger brother they both
shared a bedroom down in the basement
which was where all the funeral home
[__] was it looked like it was par like
partitioned off into like two things I
don't know if that's what it was really
like cuz there was like a door in
between and you know you close the door
but then behind the door was that's
where the gurnie and all the sink and
all that other and the freezer and [__]
was so they said they would sleeping
there and that sometimes they would see
people walking around in the room like
in the little Funeral Home area or hear
people talking sometimes they saw people
in the corner of their room like on
their side of the room Philip said that
he heard people like a person like
saying his name there was that and also
this and this kind of freaked me out
this this part they said at some point
they started sleep sleeping with all the
lights on because they were scared right
their dad got mad because he was like oh
my God my electric bill is like4
bajillion dollars and it's just like you
guys are leaving the [__] lights on
all the time because you're scared of
ghosts which don't exist so he goes
through and takes out all of the light
bulbs except one except like one in like
a little desk lamp like right there next
to their bed and they said that after
that happened then the lights in their
bedroom like the overhead lights would
go off and on even though there was no
bulbs in there and they also said that
their sister Jennifer who I don't know
how old she was she was little about
seven or eight yeah she looked about
seven that she came downstairs and was
flicking the switch back and forth but
they were implying that she was
possessed like somebody was making her
do that but they're like that sh they
shouldn't have been able to come on the
lights because they weren't they implied
bulbs up that's not what they implied
because
when the boy said he woke up cuz the
lights were flickering on and on he was
looking up there was there was no light
bulb in in there and he looked at the
staircase the staircase where you know
from from upstairs and standing there
was his sister oh that's right she was
she's not possessed it was like a ghost
yeah and then that looked like her he
goes what are you and you know what are
you doing what are you doing and then
she ran up the stairs and he ran after
her and her parents were at the top of
the stairs at the table and she goes did
she just run through here and Sayes no
she's upstair she's been asleep all
night that's right that's right I forgot
about that so it was it was just an
apparition of her yeah so so there was
that so it started doing weird [__] like
that um Phillip the 14-year-old who had
cancer seemed to be the most affected
like I said the other kids saw [__] too
Carmen saw [__] too but seemed to kind
of blow it
off so the kids all saw this stuff they
were freaking out philli starts his
personality starts changing he starts
getting real aggressive he starts like
you know wearing black and Goth out like
you do staying in his room he doesn't
want his brother being in the room with
him anymore even though they've
previously been really close I said it
it sounded to me just like he was
turning into a teenager like that just
happens but implication being that this
entity whatever it was was whether it
was demonic or whatever was like talking
to him and like talking him into doing
stuff and at this point too he starts
saying that that it was telling him to
hurt his family and he did they kind of
sugarcoated this in The Haunting episode
a little bit they did show it didn't
they in the fictional
movie um but not still not real
graphic um but they said that Phillip
tried to sexually assault his cousin
right Tammy she woke up and he was down
at the foot of the bed pulling the
covers off of her right she said get out
of here and he jumped on the [__] bed
and going sh trying to get her to be
quiet as and she started started
screaming her mom came in and they they
drove him out of there and then they
called the uh the metal hospital they
took him out of and they took him out
yeah so he was in the mental hospital
for a while and then didn't he say like
when they were taking him away it's like
Oh They'll be after you now or something
yeah he said now that I'm gone they'll
be after you right that's what he told
them and then likeed supposedly after
that yeah and like I said in the
haunting episode I guess I understand
why they did this they did not even
mention the but horking yeah they did
not mention I don't think that's
happened till later it didn't but they
still didn't mention it they didn't they
didn't mention it in the movie movie
either sexual assaults either no they
pretty much the closest they got they
did imply that Philip tried to sexually
assault his cousin like he went up to
her room and jumped on her and stuff and
also um I think they did just sort of
mention that
tamy um I don't even know if they
mentioned this because I remember they
mentioned on the Sally Jesse show but um
but Tammy said she was laying in bed and
she felt a hand like pulling her bra
strap off off all the time and I thought
they implied that it was like trying to
touch her boob yeah or it was touch or
it came up under her shirt well in the
Sally Jesse Show Carmen said that she
that at one point I don't know when this
happened they never really tell you at
what phase this happened that she saw
underneath her blouse a hand moving up
she saw the knuckles and everything on
it right uh [__] go up her front of
her dress to where her breast was and
then go over the top of her shoulder and
and and she said it disappeared into the
wall into the wall yeah like behind her
she said it she just it was like a bony
hand she said I think she said on
another one because i' heard her tell
that I think I I heard her tell that
story more than once on one of those
shows yeah they were on a lot of talk
shows back in the day and they asked her
to describe the hand she said the can
actually had a cuff on it on from from a
suit and a cufflink oh really I don't
remember her she said that's what she
said and that I remember her saying that
that was years ago though she said said
it was just like like a drawing of a
hand you know what I mean like drawing
of hands where it had like the cuff
length like pointing this way right I
got that's kind of what she said she
said that when when it came up it
actually had a cuff on it and a cuff leg
but there was no arm ghost is a [__]
perver like I said yeah weird she said
was just a bony White
Hand yeah she said well on she seemed to
apply on the Sally Jesse show that on
multiple occasions like the thing had
like pulled her covers off like while
she was sleeping but I don't know how
often that the hand coming up under the
under her shirt was and they did the
whole shower curtain thing too uh what
was your name Tammy yeah yeah Tammy said
that a real name yeah yeah she said that
uh um she could feel its hand coming up
through the bed remember yeah gra and
grabbing her she said it was like and
then another time she said it one time
it felt like a thousands of hands all
over yeah another time yeah that's right
she did say that didn't she yeah so so
it's interesting that on a haunting you
know the pilot episode they didn't
really bring up any of the sexual
assault stuff maybe I don't know if they
just thought that would be too salacious
it's supposed to be a family show or if
they thought it was too outlandish like
maybe people wouldn't buy it I'm not
really sure I think the Atlanta [__]
[__] that was the most impressive
part of that's what I mean it's just
kind of like because not only did Tammy
have that stuff happened to her
allegedly but Carmen both Carmen and her
husband said that this entity had like
sexually assaulted them yeah it was a
sexually assaulting Poltergeist of some
sort right that could make
apparitions weird Danny says the son
with cancer died because the cancer came
back later on in his life eventually
yeah he did um when they made The
Haunting episode in 2002 um that was
prior to his death so they were like oh
you know his cancer went into remission
and he's fine and everything like that
but he did actually die later on I don't
remember how old he was maybe in his 20s
or 30s 30s um he been in his 30s but
yeah I think that he um but he did die
later on with the cancer returned in
2002 he probably been in his 30s yeah
that's right because he was older than
me yeah so cuz he was 14 in
yeah which is about actually no that's
that's the same age as me same yeah
that's the same age as me cuz I was also
14 in 1986 yeah so he yeah he's been
about 30 yeah yeah that's right so yeah
he probably he died after 2002 so yeah
he was in his 30s but yeah he did die
later on so so they didn't really go
into that which like I said to me was
one it's probably like the least
believable I guess or the aspect of the
case that people would find least
believable I guess but um and like I
said I can understand why they didn't
want to put it in there they didn't
mention it in the fictional movie either
and I'm going to say the fictional movie
um is a good film but um after a certain
point it doesn't really have much to do
with the actual case anymore yeah it
diverges from it pretty great it
diverges pretty wildly I understand that
they were trying to make a narrative
behind it like why this was happening in
this funeral home like why it was
haunted in this particular way like who
the ghosts were and [__] but yeah it's a
decent flick it is yeah but really I I
prefer the [__] haunting episode this
this one here like you said I had
forgotten how crude the old haunting
episodes were crude yeah of slow moving
because you know they they were they
were movie length they were 90 minutes
the pilots cuz they were trying to see
if it would be as successful which it
was obviously because that [__] shows
it had some really good Drone footage of
the snow and
everything um but it was that was kind
of ahead of its time for 2002 to have
some Drone footage a footage uh so but
uh it's it's it's the aspect ratio is
for old televisions it's very video wish
looking like V very video is looking
looks like it was uh recorded with a
video cam with with a camera or what I
was going to say a phone looks like it
was made off a phone kind
of no I guess not it wasn't that bad
well well I don't know just something
about the the motion it wasn't it did
the later ones were almost like was like
Cinema the other ones yeah they did
actually try in the later Seasons you
could tell that they were trying to go
for more like a cinematic kind of look
to them which you know and a kind of
setup like that yeah the early ones were
very much early 2000s TV almost kind of
like Blair Witch Project not quite that
janky but not that janky but because I
mean Blair Witch Project was made with
like really cheap
equipment um Danny says the whole Spirit
medium idea for the Hollywood version
was a nice touch I mean to have a seance
in a funeral home is creepy as [__] yeah
and I will say that that angle didn't
come from nowhere because at least
according to Carmen snaker
she did find she didn't find like a
whole cache of like weird dead people
photos like they did in the movie but
she said that they did find a couple
photos of you know the dear departed and
like toe tags and [__] like that so I'm
guessing that that just little germ of
an idea is where they got the whole
backstory that's in the Hollywood movie
from 2009 which I did like that I like
cuz I like anything to do with
spiritualism or mediums or anything like
that so I like and seances and ectoplasm
and all that kind of stuff so I did like
that angle
but like I said after a time it just
went way off so if you're and it's weird
because you watch the movie and it say
based on the true story which I'm like
yeah like the first 20 30 minutes are
maybe but like after that it just goes
completely crazy like it doesn't have
anything to do with with what they
claimed yeah they didn't have any
priests in there did they
um just the one guy okay now I will say
that the haunted in Connecticut 2009
that's right because for a second I'm
sitting there I was like this is not in
The Conjuring universe is it with the
ones with the with the Warren as
characters like with Vera farer and
Patrick Wilson is that that dude's name
I can't remember with the two of them
yeah um which are good like those are
good movies too but I was like I'm
pretty sure this is not in The Conjuring
Universe I said but we'll see cuz I had
seen it a lot I saw it before but it was
a long time ago
so I was just like I'm pretty sure the
Warren aren't in this um which is fine
with me um and yes I was right they
actually replaced the Warren which who
did show up at the caker house in real
life um with just like a priest
character played by Elias catas who I
really like a lot I still you know
what's hilarious he's been in a million
things I know that but it's like I still
remember him from that John Hughes movie
Some Kind of Wonderful like as the skin
head punk rocker dude who like carved
like this skeleton girl with braids like
on his desk and then he goes to the dude
he's like this is what my girlfriend
would look like without skin I don't
know why I remember that but that was
him from that movie so he's in this as a
priest who is also dying of cancer and
he meets the charact who's named Matt in
the movie right like like I said they
Chang the they change it to the Campbell
family so they Chang all their names so
he meets Matt at the Cancer Treatment
Center and uh they get to talking about
but the implication in the movie and I
think this kind of came from real life
too because weren't they saying that
maybe the reason that Phillip which is
the kid's name in real life um was kind
of the most tormented by The Entity or
entities or whatever it was was because
he was much closer to death than
everyone else and they kind of take that
Concept in the movie and kind of run
with it cuz for a lot of it he SE sees
[__] and nobody else does you know like
I think they even took some stuff that
Carmen saw or said she saw in real life
like the bloody mop water and they and
the whole thing about the dishes like
putting the dishes out on the table and
then they go back in the cabinet they
actually make the character of Matt that
happens to him in the movie but Carmen
doesn't see it yeah they flipped a lot
of stuff around they flipped a lot of
stuff around to make it look like it was
just him that was experiencing the stuff
and nobody else did but in real life
like I said all of the kids said that
they saw stuff and then Carmen said she
saw stuff later on and then obviously
the husband um you know got butt horked
and various other things what what else
did he say happened to him did he say he
saw some [__] I don't remember if he
said
anything about um other paranormal
manifestations other than maybe I was
just so distracted by the but horking
that I was just kind of like the Imp he
was under the impression that he saw the
same things that they saw that he was in
in okay another thing that he saw is he
went to work and his his car oh that's
right yeah drove into the building that
he was in did they put that in the movie
movie I think they did yeah because that
was another thing that because their
whole thing was because a lot of people
when they were when the snakers were on
Sally Jesse Rafael a lot of the people
in the audience because you know how
they [__] do in these talk show
audiences everybody has to just like
stand up and yell at you and they're
like why don't you just leave why didn't
you move blah blah blah like if it was
my kids I'd be out of there the first
night y y you know they all kind of for
[__] armchair Warriors so well they
said well it followed us yeah and
apparently they said that Allan the dad
like he went to work at the construction
site he was working at and his truck
started itself up and drove into the
building that he was in yeah which I
guess was just like a trailer type
situation so they did put that they did
put that in the haunting episode I don't
remember if they put it in the actual
then the fiction he was seeing he was
seeing the sexual assaults though
sometimes when he was there and I think
he was seeing those apparition if I
remember correctly he we had we have to
dig up some other shows yeah when on the
talk shows yeah I think he he he
remembered seeing quite a bit from or I
remember him saying that he saw quite a
bit actually yeah so he you know he
believed it I will say one thing that I
did really like about the hollywoodized
version um like I said don't watch it if
you're going to do I don't know why
you'd be doing a report on The sticar
Haunting but if you were for school or
something
um don't watch that movie thinking
that's going to be accurate because it's
absolutely not uh especially after the
first 20 30 minutes or so it just it
goes off in its own Direction which is
fine but um uh so so I kind of feel like
I did like all the acting in it was
really good I'm GNA say that uh I love
Virginia Madson um you know she's been
in a million things I obviously remember
her from Candyman from 1982 Martin
Donovan is in it who I [__] love
Martin Donovan uh he was in all those H
heartley movies like back in the day he
was also in one of the Masters of Horror
episodes uh I think it was the right to
life one which was kind of based on that
Terry shyo case if you guys remember
that um but yeah so but I've always
really liked him as an actor I don't
know how accurate it is because in the
movie they made him like a recovering
alcoholic like it didn't play too much
into the plot but they did kind of bring
it up a couple couple times that he had
been a drunk and he was just kind of
like the the worse [__] got like the
more stressful it got like the more he
was like tempted to go back into the
drinking and then like he went to a bar
one night and got shitfaced and and I
kind of liked that after that like he
came back to the house and they sort of
took the whole thing about the dad
unscrewing all the light bulbs which
apparently did he did in real life but
in the movie they made it so he comes
back drunk from the bar he's like why
are all these lights on in the house and
he smashes all the light bulbs so I kind
of like that they dramatized it like
that because it's kind of based on
something that really happened but they
had not really he turn he he got he's
like why is the you know why is the
bills like this and he ran he collected
all the light bulbs yeah yeah like in
real life he was just kind of like why
is the electric bill so high why you
kids are sleeping with the lights on all
the time so he just went and unscrewed
all the light bulbs but in the movie
like he comes home drunk and he's like
all the [__] lights are on and he
smashes them all so like I said it was
kind of the same thing but they just
like overd dramatized it so if you
haven't seen the movie like I said it's
not a great movie it's it's a fine it's
fine um it had some creepy moments
little jump scary um for me but like I
said all of the acting was really good
it had like some really creepy imagery
in it I really liked all the um the
creepy old Seance imagery like the old
um you know people like posing next to
their dead relatives like they used to
do back in the day like all the bodies
that had all the writing writing on it
um did you guys notice I don't know if
you guys noticed this but a couple of
the bodies pretty sure they were putting
some little Easter eggs in there because
I know that that I saw one of the words
on one of the bodies was saperia yeah
and I'm pretty sure it said tenra also
I'm like somebody's a Dario Argento fan
I see that I see you but um I like that
although I will say was I not paying
attention the lore behind it a little
convoluted going to say what exactly was
the guy okay so Jonah was the boy that
Matt was seeing like in his visions and
stuff who had lived in this house yeah
and then he had that Mad Doctor guy sort
of who was trying to amplify his powers
like to his medium Powers by doing some
kind of like necromancy like some kind
of black magic I never really got what
with the dead body so he stole dead
bodies cuz they said there were like a
100 dead bodies like in the cemetery
like they found all these empty Graves
and he would bring them back to the
house and like write all these like
incantations and [__] like on their skin
yeah and then he was keeping them in the
house cuz obviously they they yo they
cut their eyelids off which was like
pretty nasty yeah that was probably that
was really the only like squirmy moment
in this cuz it's PG-13 so they didn't go
too crazy like with the gore or anything
but they did show people like somebody
cutting someone's eyelids off so there's
that but so they find a box of eyelids
later on as you do if you're in a house
and you find a box of eyelids maybe
maybe move out get get your damage
deposit back get the [__] out of there
I'm just saying so it's just kind of
like so he steals all these bodies he
wrotes these incant ations on them and
then he stashes the bodies in the
house right but it's like so I didn't
get the connection between why are we
keeping the bodies in the house which
you would think you would have smelled I
would have thought after a while cuz how
long has this house been abandoned I
don't know a long time those things were
there then well the thing about it when
they do the
flashback Jonah is at the um doing the
Seance and he has the ectoplasm comes
out of his mouth which is the you know
the very icon IC image that's on the
poster and then with the whole
amplification deal that the guy was
doing it like Cooks everybody at the
Seance like it just it burns everybody
up yeah and then he ends up in the
crematorium in the funeral home and it
comes on by itself and burns him up
alive yeah so they're saying well Elias
kot's character the priest he goes down
there and he finds the remains of Jonah
and takes them outside the house but
then he's like oh [__] I [__] up like
Jonah was actually keeping all the other
spirits of the bodies like contained and
now they're all like running around
loose or whatever and so that's how that
so I'm just going to say that I wasn't
super clear and I've seen the movie two
times at this point I wasn't super clear
on how we got from point A to point B
with the dead bodies you know Visa the
dead bodies in the house like what were
they doing in there why were they still
in there um what was going on with that
did they just get left in there because
the dude got burned up I'm guessing I
did not understand the whole Seance I
didn't understand that part actually
yeah like I kind of got it but I wasn't
real clear on all the details I didn't
know what they were talking about I yeah
it was just creepy [__] they were
showing me I'm going yeah okay that's
creepy which like I said I did like all
that creepy like I liked all that creepy
imagery like of him like busting out the
the doors like at the end and all his
bodies like flopping out like they have
writing all over them and [__] that was
like really cool they're preserved
they're all in bomb
I guess so they're not they're not
rotting you would think they still would
after all that oh yeah but it's the
movies they' rot a bit they'd be
stinking like crazy that's what I was
think it's like man what's that [__]
smelling here you at least smell it from
alide yeah that's what You' think yeah I
don't really know so yeah so that whole
that whole angle like it's a good angle
for a story but it was added like
obviously there were no bodies left in
the real sneaker house it's not their
house they just rented it yeah um you
know they just moved in there creepy
[__] started happening didn't they say
like that all the um you know how they
had the uh all the crucifixes and [__]
like over the doors and stuff like you
would have in a funeral home and it's
like one by one they like disappeared uh
that was in that was in the Summer Wind
wasn't it no no no that was it happened
in this one too because even in a
haunting episode remember she they keep
GL I don't think they he looked they
brought a lot of attention to it but
it's like they kept looking up over the
doors and there' be like a little dust
thing like where the crucifix was and
now it's gone yeah yeah yeah and then
um they had a little thing that was like
it had a little cross and then it was
like a little what do they call that
thing like a little reliquary deal where
you P it and they would put their keys
in there and like she there's one part
where she comes in and goes to drop her
keys in the thing and it's gone and then
she's like hey this thing disappeared
but they were like worried about other
[__] so they didn't really focus on it
so that was another thing that I don't
know if they really went into that in
the fictional movie or not like I said
the fictional movie is good it's not you
know it's kind of a middle of the road
haunt ating movie I think the thing that
elevates it is the acting which is great
and um just like I like a lot of the
creepy imagery because I really love
Seance imagery I love that old like
spiritualist type of thing and I really
like all the actors in it um but other
than that it's pretty middle of the road
like haunted house type of story and
like I said after the First Act it's
nothing like the actual like what the
actual story describes movie is actually
better than a lot of the [__]
they'll come out with today
because it's it's just very standard
just standard horror movie yeah yeah
Haunted House movie but it's decent it's
yeah like like I said I've seen better
I've seen worse um you know I I think
all the actors did a really good job
even the the actor that played the kid
was good even though he's I mean they
made him look like hell but he had
cancer you know what I mean um but and I
think it was a good idea for a backstory
but like I said I think it was a little
too maybe a little too out there
especially like considering
what the actual uh backstory of the case
was but you know as I said and we talk
about this a lot because you talk about
the Mammoth Mountain case that you went
through yeah you were like it doesn't
have a plot like if they made a movie
out of it yeah they would have to have
they would have to come up with some
kind of backstory about like why did it
happen like linking all the events
together because that's just what you do
for a fictional story like real life
isn't like that though
yeah a real Poltergeist case is just
random [__]
random random occurrences that are
happening one after another right that
are impressive it's definitely trying to
impress you with what it can do we were
trying to figure out what it all meant
it didn't mean anything it was just
trying to impress you yeah because when
you told me all this stuff it just
seemed like each each individual
incident was creepy but it's like all
together it didn't like add up to a
narrative so I feel like if you're going
to make it into a three
script like to make a successful movie
out of it you have to have some kind of
through line you have to have some kind
of narrative so that's what they did
here I think they went a little out
there with it but it's fine if you
didn't know anything about the real case
then it probably wouldn't bother you all
that much real Poltergeist just do
things in the moment there's no plan you
know there's no reason for it yeah it
just does things in the moment and
really and the way that the sneers
described their case whe whether it
happened or not I don't really know but
just like all the [__] they said it
didn't really make a lot of sense like
it didn't it didn't all tie together
like into one narrative it was just
random [__] kind of in general think
that something like a poltergeist
happened there some of that stuff I
think they did see um a poltergeist
could do that if it wanted
to but uh it there's no like I said
there's no real narrative or purpose to
it can't read too much into it it just
does things in the moment and that
particular one evidently had a sexual
bent to it which some of them do like I
said we talked about the Doris bther
case which also had that kind of uh that
kind of energy to it yeah which uh it's
not common but you do see it in some
Poltergeist cases the more it would
scare you the more scared you would you
you would you get in aureu episodes the
the uh the more threatening the
Poltergeist fedoma becomes so if it had
a sexual Bend to it and then it scared
the [__] out of you it would get more
and more Sinister but it evidently
wasn't real consistent because it would
stop doing that kind of stuff it would
do different
things according to their story yeah it
didn't stay just on the sexual angle
there was a lot of apparitions too which
I feel like you don't see a lot in
Poltergeist type cases it's not unheard
of but it's not super common either
apparitions or vision
yeah CU I don't know I don't I don't I
really can't really imagine a
poltergeist trying to go through all the
problem all the trouble of making a 3D
solid looking Apparition like a
character like a like a like a
marionette character it'd be easier for
that thing to just put an image in your
head like an like a like a hallucination
and you thought you saw it it'd be a lot
easier yeah less energy yeah just like
make you see make you see something it's
not there right be a lot
easier John says it would be funny if
the ghost had to oops if the ghost had
to um go around the neighborhood
informing everyone he was a registered
sex offender yeah like John curo the big
leowski right yeah well see every time
we watch an episode of a haunting and
they're you know just like oh we
exercise the ghost to smell of sanctity
blah blah cuz which is apropo in this
because the Warren had something to do
with it although she didn't say smell of
sanctity you smell that that's the smell
of sanctity yeah with her little like
her
little the little bottle she keeps in
her car like you know what I mean the
air freshener like no that's Ed farting
probably yeah Ed Warren's fart smell
like roses everybody knows that he has a
genetic disorder yeah he has a way to do
it yeah he sprays it up in sprays it up
in there sprays it up yeah he sphincters
it he Keers
it and then he comes in and releases it
I love how he made that into a verb so
kin
that's what we're going to call it from
now on something that's when you put it
in your ass putting something up your
ass for for later dispersal yeah yeah
yeah yeah we were we were making jokes
about that but I the first thing I
always think of is that yeah we exercise
the ghost from this house and
everybody's like oh Sho that's over and
stuff like that I'm like yeah you just
sent it to the [__] neighbor's house
thanks a lot [__] like the the ghost
is like I don't care I'm just going to
go in the window next door and like
possess their teenage daughter or
whatever the [__] so I was just kind I
think that's what's going to happen
because wasn't there one episode of
Haunting I can't remember what one it
was but um they said that they
exercised you know or banish the spirit
or whatever and then didn't the guy
didn't he say he was like driving and
saw the ghost like standing in the woods
like like a around the block or some
[__] yeah what and I can't remember was
a pretty good one but it's like that and
that made me laugh cuz I said that's
what I imagin every single time that the
ghost is just like I'm just going to go
next door like I'm just going to stand
here in the street no I guess it wasn't
the on with the spirits in the woods I
forgot which one that was yeah it wasn't
that one it was like it was in a house
yeah and then like later he saw it just
like standing out in like an empty lot
or something yeah looking at him like
looking at him like I'm still here
[__] and just like yeah but
you're not in my house anymore so you
know what I mean it's always was that
kind of situation um yeah uh let me see
um yeah elas cus and let me in was a
great role yeah um Let Me In was
actually one of the few American remakes
of a foreign film that was was actually
pretty [__] good I mean Let the Right
One In is better but let me in was also
pretty good book is good too if you
haven't uh read
that um yeah Danny says those dead
people photos make an appearance in the
film The Others oh my God we really need
to review that one of these days because
I love that [__] movie and I don't
think Tom's ever seen it and he'd
probably like really dig it because I
think that movie is like super creepy
but see that's the thing that imagery is
just so effective because there was a
reason behind it why the victorians took
pictures of themselves with their dead
relatives cuz like nowadays you're just
like what that's weird as [__] like it's
really morbid but I mean photography was
not that common back then so it's like a
lot of times especially if you're if the
dead person was like a little kid like
you didn't have any photographs of them
so it's like how are you supposed to
remember them it's like the only time
you could take a photograph of them is
after they were already dead the weird
thing about it though is that the
creepiest ones to me are the ones with
the moms that are but they put like a
black like cover over themselves so it's
like you can't see them even though you
obviously can cuz it's like a person
with a black sheet over their head and
they're just like holding the dead baby
so it's that is like so [__] creepy I
was just like why not just put the mom
and the baby in there that just seems
like less unsettling I don't know why
you'd want to have a photo of just the
dead baby with like an obvious obviously
that's the mom like holding it but
they're covered up with a black sheet
that was always like really weird to me
but like I said it's not once you know
the context it's not as I mean it's
still creepy the photos are still creepy
but um once you know the context it's
not quite as creepy it's just kind of
sad but I don't get the ones where the
moms are covered up with Black Sheets
though that's like super bizarre um Hugo
said have I seen the new Exorcist um we
didn't really bother with it it we saw
the trailer and it's like well it
doesn't look too bad but we just didn't
get around to it and then it seemed like
I was seeing reviews of it everybody's
like oh my God don't bother it's awful
um so we just didn't bother with it you
know I'll probably see it one of these
days but I'm really behind on I haven't
even seen Evil Dead rise yet even though
it's on [__] Amazon Prime and I'll
get around to it one of these days but I
still haven't [__] seen it thank you
very much Aon that's very very nice of
you thank you very much haven't been to
aive in a while love your shows as
always thank you a that's
awesome uh John says The Last Exorcism
was okay yeah that I liked that one too
um and I lik The Exorcism of Emily Rose
yeah that was also good that was based
on wasn't Exorcism of Emily Rose I think
that was based on the Analise M case um
but I think they transplanted it to
America and it had the actress what's
that actress's name that played remember
the actress that played Dexter's sister
on Dexter yeah yeah um she's she's in it
yeah um but yeah Exorcism of Emily Rose
is actually pretty good and The Last
Exorcism is good too is that the one
that I'm thinking of that's found
footage or a mockumentary wasn't it ooh
pookies on yeah Pooky
on um yeah Danny says new Exorcist was
mediocre nothing special about it unlike
The Last Exorcism yeah I really liked
the last exorcism I remember liking that
one but yeah so I don't know it's I
really I do like The Haunting in
Connecticut but like I said it's kind of
a middleof the
road horror movie yeah you know what I
mean not fantastic not it's just it's
just kind of okay you haven't seen it
you can watch it like it's kind of
creepy yeah like I said the acting I
think elevates it cuz there's really
good actors in this um and I do like the
idea behind it but like I said it's not
super close to the true story and I
think they went a little far with the
believability yeah of it um but that's
kind of I don't know that's a minor
criticism I think overall like it's a
decent very Loosely based very Loosely
very Loosely like I said it does have
like some aspects of [__] that happened
in the real case like the bloody mop
water and um you know the the ex funeral
home and them
seeing apparitions like a man in a suit
and stuff like that but after that they
just kind of go in Wild Direction think
what this is is that they wanted to make
a horror movie they already had the
script written then they said you know
if we associate this with an actual case
we'll say it's based on that yeah we'll
add some details like from the actual
case and they added some it does kind of
seem the beginning of the case in in the
scenario yeah that's that's no the whole
plot it has nothing to do with the S
case and I I feel like that happens a
lot um maybe it happens in other genres
too but I am aware of it happening a lot
with horror where sometimes there'll be
just like a random script that's
floating around Hollywood and people are
like hey this script is kind of good but
probably no one will go see it because
it's not associated with an existing IP
so let's slap an amville thing on it and
you know we'll have one scene take place
that the amville house or somebody will
mention amville or something like that
so they'll just kind of like try to
shoehorn into like something like
something with some name recognition so
I do kind of feel like they do I think
that some of the later sequels
especially of maybe like the Hellraiser
movies and stuff like that I think those
were completely unrelated scripts that
they just kind of like massaged into
like to fit into the lore what was that
four that was happening in California
and they had the damn lamp was that the
fourth one no I think that was the the
fifth one or the sixth
I think there's well cuz the thing about
it is that the Amityville house there's
no copyright on that as far as I know
because it's just a house it's a real
quote unquote real haunting well it's a
real hoax haunting that happened but so
I'm guessing that you can write whatever
the [__] you want about that case as
long as you don't use any real people
because I know that Amityville 2 was
very Loosely based on the actual defo
murders but they changed everyone's name
and they changed the year that it
happened and they kind of changed some
of the details and stuff so I guess they
wouldn't get in trouble but there was
the one yeah we actually saw it at on
Rift tracks live at the theater it's
just called Amityville it's about time I
think so but I don't know what number in
the series it was if you could even call
it that and it's basically the only
thing it has to do with Amityville is
like it take the whole thing takes place
in California it's not in the Amityville
house it's not at Long Island or nothing
it's like the only thing is like doesn't
the old lady buy a clock that used to
sit in the Amityville house and the
[__] clock is possessed by whatever
[__] demon like and yeah it's a clock
I thought it was a damn lamp oh yeah
yeah it's right it's a lamp it's a lamp
it's a lamp it's a haunted lamp a
haunted lamp and we're not even making
that the lamp looks like a bent ass tree
like like a hand like kind of like a a
man with a damn glass globe on the top
it has nothing to do with the Amity Bill
nothing it was just and you can tell and
you can that that was just like a
completely random arm and it was that
they were like hey can we say that this
haunted lamp SL they just came from the
Amityville house yeah they just slapped
Amityville onto it right it had nothing
to do with that [__] I mean I get why
they do that they're just trying to make
money trying to make money see the movie
but it's pretty OB if you're going to
pay a screenwriter to kind of [__] with
it it's at least tie it in more than
that I guess that screenwriter they're
like they didn't pay them all that much
they're like [__] that it's just I'm
going to have one scene where I think
they gave a [__] they did not they just
looked at the numbers they say okay well
this is amville 5 statistically how much
money is it going to make okay it's
going to be make most most of the money
on VHS so look it doesn't really matter
all right yeah we're going to spend x
amount of money on it like $2 million
under budget we'll use this script here
we'll just say it's Aville there it is
yeah it's like we'll just put a scene at
the beginning with like this this like
being look look what this lamp was in
the Amityville house yeah so it's like
we just we send one person out to get
some shots of the outside of the amville
or a house that looks like the amville
cuz actually the Amityville house in
Long Island doesn't look like that
anymore no they changed those windows
they changed the windows on purpose
because everybody was like parking out
in their front yard and like taking
pictures of it so you can't really blame
them CU I'm pretty sure that house is
still there but it doesn't look anything
the same doesn't look anything the same
uh Danny says amville dollhouse is
really good direct to video film with
really good makeup and effects far
better than the Amityville remake I
don't think I've ever seen the
Amityville dollhouse one we'll have to
watch that one of these days that's just
more of them trying toh sell a A Haunted
House movie by slapping the amville
title on it that's okay if it's a good
horror movie whatever yeah yeah John
says what's that movie about a haunted
bong I'm pretty sure it was called evil
was it called evil bong well there was
was that tra CU I think there was one
that was Ginger dead man which has I
think Gary Bucy in it Ginger Dead Man
versus evil bong which I'm pretty sure
is a traa film and I'm kind of I see it
when I'm scrolling through stuff on tub
because I think it's on tub or Amazon
Prime and I'm kind of tempted to watch
it but I don't know if I watch it or not
of course that would have Gary booy in
it of course I'm pretty sure garyo he
was in ginger dead man it's called
ginger dead man yeah and in the magic
bomb bomb haunted bomb it's e it's
an watch just stand back stand back I
got to act hold on stand back big ass
teeth yeah yeah yeah he's crazy I like
him though I like Gary boo we should do
Ginger dead we should do Ginger dead man
for Christmas like for the Christmas
review
yeah booy can chew up scenery man you if
you [__] tell him to go for he's not
going to phone it in he's going to [__]
the whole place up and and he's in a
really good movie good really good
Crustle movie called Soldier where he
plays he plays the [__] he's been in
some good [__] yeah
heco in charge of all the damn replicant
soldiers and [__] he no don't if it
ain't broke don't fix it then the new
command comes in tries to [__] it all I
love Soldier it's a good movie good
Crustle movie it's
slow kind of slow but if you're a
veteran you'll like Charles band yeah
you're right you you you if you're a
veteran you'd like uh you'd like a
soldier about crussell and he's like a
genetically engineered or no raised from
birth Soldier and then they're getting
replaced by these genetically engineered
guys who are like replicant like Roy
Batty Roy bades yeah it is a little bit
in the Blade Runner Universe it's
supposed to be in the Blade Runner
Universe it's me Jay said my high school
fizzed teacher used to babysit for the
after the defos at the idville house she
said she never saw anything uh and the
place was fine she stayed
overnight um yeah I I kind of suspect we
did a show about the am evil haunting a
while back and I've read the book by Jay
Anon I've seen you know the movie I saw
the Remake and we've seen interviews
with um you know the family members and
[__] like that I suspect that that was
they just made that
up I suspect they made it up be well I
mean if you if you didn't have a lot of
money well CU that's kind of a um a
charge that a lot of people aimed at the
sneakers too was that oh you guys didn't
start talking about like all this
haunting [__] until you got two months
behind on your rent yeah um and they
were just like because a lot of their
neighbors and stuff like that and I
think even the landlord said that they
were like trying to make money off of
the [__] I can see how the Amityville
people yeah uh the lutzes I and see how
they would want to do that because that
house like there was a multiple murder
that happened in that house they didn't
make that up so you know that's
documented so I can see why and the dude
did say he probably was just trying to
get an insanity defense but he did say
that voices told them to do it yeah so
that's absolutely something you could
use the things with the sneakers and
them falling behind rent if you look at
Poltergeist phenomenon the case has
always taken place in a family that has
a lot of [__] stress in it and that
includes a lot of the stress is
financial stress well they were under a
lot of financial stress they were losing
[__] tons of money trying to keep that
boy from dying yeah so it's the kind of
environment that a poltergeist would
actually could be generated because I
believe they're generated generated by
the [__] subconscious
mind and uh I think there might be group
Synergy involved in it too yeah where
it's more than one person kind of
helping it
grow
yeah so just because just because they
were behind in rent that doesn't mean it
didn't happen yeah because yeah
obviously they were under a lot of
financial strength Fred Ed Dunham who is
part of The Haunting in Florida run into
him every now and then yeah he lives
around here yeah that's kind of what
they said about him well he was falling
behind on his
rent no I don't first of he did I think
he did
say that was because the the [__] the
hauntings there was disturbing the
family so much he wasn't getting a lot
of work in right so so that was part of
it but um he was some say he was trying
to get out of his out of his lease but I
don't think he was I don't think he was
you know he he was a contractor he could
have made a lot of money I mean you've
talked to him in real life and he
doesn't really seem like the type of
dude that would make some [__] up like
that yeah he's still ex ex Army Ranger
got guy wow but uh he said it did happen
um he didn't really want to talk about
that much though with me I I tried to
ask him I says what exactly did you see
up on up on the roof cuz in in The
Haunting episode he said he could he
heard footsteps sounded like somebody
walking around in the Attic he ran out
but there evidently was no real attic it
was just a ceiling like Florida has
that might have been crawl spaces or
something up there um I don't know but
he ran out the front yard to look to see
who was on the roof and in in the uh in
the episode
uh I think they show a guy up
there I asked him what it was what what
he actually saw and he said it was just
it was a black figure that's all he said
it was a black figure he could couldn't
quite really make it out it was just
moving up there on the roof so he said
he wasn't sure what it was it was just a
presence and I was like all right it
kind of sounds like something that you
would see in polter guys
type phenomenon and there was he had
kids in the house I don't know if they
were his kids or his wife I guess they
were from that same
wife and if I remember correctly I think
they were kind of the right age for
Poltergeist but like I said it wasn't
there I drove by that house yeah we know
where it is I know where it is I drove
by it and stopped out in front of it and
see if I could feel anything weird like
like a mammoth I didn't feel anything
though I wasn't gonna go knock on the
door either yeah because that'd be kind
of weird yeah like look I wonder if they
get that all the time I like hey I saw
that episode of Haunting can I come in
and see if like the [__] goes I
forgot the address but I could find it
if I wanted to but I'm not going to
[__] release it it's in Deltona right
it's in Deltona yeah yeah which is just
in a regular
suburban area near
Lake yeah like you said it's a different
house than the one they showed on the
yeah they show a house in the it's on
the same street though yeah that that
that's the house on the corner it's a
few houses down from that one yeah yeah
they use that one cuz that one looked a
lot better
yeah I think they tend to do that they
want something that looks yeah you know
cinematic it wasn't a bad looking house
it's just it just didn't look that good
looks like one of those kind of old
Florida houses from like the 50s or
whatever or the 60s no it just uh it was
white yeah I guess it was just like a
colonial but it it was like
sideways narrow and deep went in deep
yeah almost like a giant shotgun house
oh you know what I mean so maybe they
thought it wouldn't look good on camera
yeah it didn't look like look I think it
was made in a time when there the houses
were closer together you know what I
mean the other ones are now gone other
houses are there are there
instead yeah that's how I remember it
Danny said the part where the demon
drove the father's car without it him
even being in it was terrifying yeah I
mean if that really happened then the
[__] like follow left that [__] in
neutral I mean yeah maybe and it rolled
down the hill he was like whoops and
then he just wanted to like not get in
trouble with his wife so he's like the
demon did it you know what I mean I
could I could see doing that if I did
some dumb [__] like that I'd probably
tell you a polter guys did it
too when I was living when I was living
in on Signal Hill Boston I had this
[__] Italian convertible it was an
old [__] Fiat
spider it was pretty cool it [__] it
was a blue car it had a [__] tan
dropped off roof on it and I lived on
top of Signal Hill and I would park my
car places put the emergency breake on
because it was a stick shift put the
emergency brake on [__] go then come
back to [__] work the next day and
I'm like where the [__] is my car I go
oh there it is it' be it'd be down the
hill it roll down the hill know it was
rolling down the hill fck it would roll
down the hill slowly a few inches at per
hour oh my God that's funny and when
somebody moved their car they would back
out and then it would slowly take that
position and then evidently it would
pass in PE front of people's [__]
driveways oh my God that's funny yeah
but it took a long time but there must
could have been that should have been
you know it had to have been that some
of those driveways were covered but I
guess it was in the middle of the night
right and nobody noticed but it took me
like three or four times to figure out
figure out what the [__] was happening
was rolling down [__] backwards or
forwards do it forwards too that's
really funny yeah I mean I guess it's a
good thing it's well I was going to say
it's a good thing it didn't have anybody
as car found it in between parking
spaces taking the taking two parking
spaces I was like I know I didn't do
that yeah like there I went in there and
hit the emergency break and [__] head
the car went back I go that that thing
is [__]
rolling real slow
huh that's crazy
yeah all right are you ready to wrap it
up we've been on for like an hour and a
half yeah all right so it's Monday night
tomorrow I will probably do a stream by
myself at some point if I have time um
I'm going to review the
2008 Canadian horror film ponti pool
which I just uh watched earlier today so
it'll probably be I don't know two three
o'clock in the afternoon something like
that but yeah I'll probably be around at
some point tomorrow and then on
Wednesday we're doing our main show
which is GNA be about man eating animals
okay cuz remember we got that idea when
we were watching um yeah watch The
Unexplained the William Shatner one and
they did whoops and they did an episode
about that and I was like oh my God that
would make a good show so I put it in
the poll and it one looks like Tammy
showed up yeah she's been here a while
she been here yeah she's been here a
while all right so so yeah so drop by
tomorrow if you can
whenever I go on I'm not sure what time
it's going to be uh because I'm going to
be talking about Ponty pool um and then
Wednesday we're doing the man eating
animal show so that should be super fun
uh thank you very much Aaron for super
chats and thanks for hanging out with us
on this Monday evening yeah you always
give us a super thanks if you're
listening to record that's right uh so I
will see you again tomorrow and then
you'll see both of us again on Wednesday
night uh so good night you guys